welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host his and this is another installment
of the early on in recruitment Series
where we're sitting down with people who
are in their first six to 12 18 months
of their recruitment journey to find out
what have been some of their biggest
challenges what have they learned so far
and most of all what advice do they have
for people listen to this that may be
considering a career Recruitment and
also for people that are in the the
trenches in the thick of their first
year Recruitment and that sort of
difficult stage of being in recruitment
so really excited to be joined by Ellie
today who works for a business called
Rec Hub and uh yeah we're gonna have a
bit of a chat about Ellie's career so
far and um get into it hi thanks for
having me no worries we're really
excited to chat to you obviously we're
just talking a bit beforehand on how you
got into recruitment how about the
things that you're really passionate
about but I guess where I've been
starting with people which would be
really good just to get your
um sort of uh your story on so far would
be how how has recruitment how is
working in recruitment been compared to
what you expected
um I was quite intentional with moving
into recruitment
um but in terms of how it compares to
what I expected it to be it's so
different I thought it was quite easy
you kind of posted a job ad loads of
people applied you'd send them off for
interview they got placed bills done
dusted and it's so different you know
there's so many more intricacies to it
there's so much more
um kind of brain work that's required
behind it and there's a lot of different
factors you know people management
stakeholder management
organization skills
um and yeah it's it's very different
it's a lot scarier than what I thought
it would be is probably the best word
really
yeah so obviously those things that you
said I feel like different but like in
mainly in a positive way or just there's
been things that you've had to learn and
grow with that maybe you'd least
expected
yeah yeah I think I think what it is is
when you kind of say that you want to do
a career you know you never know what
it's going to be everything's so much
different than a job description I mean
obviously especially being in
recruitment people can tell you that but
um in terms of what I actually thought
the job would be I thought it would just
be a job and it's not it's so much more
it's like you as a kind of person you
can really kind of put your all into it
and so that aspect I really really love
um but it was definitely a shock to the
system like how much kind of of myself I
would put into the job
yeah thank you for sharing that so I
guess just to just to frame out for
people so
you graduated uni with what I can see a
degree in criminology in July 2021
yeah right and then like like you shared
with me before we started this getting
into recruitment was was intentional for
you
um so you joined the business
um who worked for uh for a period and
then over the last eight months you've
then been with Rec Hub as you was really
Keen to get into a tech environment and
sort of continue progressing your
recruitment career and sort of level up
the uh environment he was in
yeah um yeah and sort of right now like
you said correct me if I'm wrong but at
the moment you are the most Junior
person in the business
yeah yeah so I've come in as a talent
associate and there are no other tele
Associates so yeah awesome so would you
what I think would be helpful for people
just quickly would be would you mind
just high level explaining the sort of
model that Rec Hub has because it isn't
the typical working for an agency you're
doing 360 recruitment or you're an
environment that does that where you're
working with multiple different clients
filling different jobs within your sort
of nation sort of focus sector could you
just tell us a bit about yeah how the
rec Hub associate how they um work and
then you can tell us being a talent
associate what does that mean sort of
day to day
yeah 100 so we are an embedded Talent
partner so we work on subscription with
different clients but for maybe three
months six months or 12 months on a
project so maybe one or up to four
Talent Partners will go into a project
and we will essentially become their
internal recruiters or we will
form a part of their internal team
um so everything on our LinkedIn skip
branded as such um and we work solely
for that client for that entire period
of time
um meaning they could essentially get
unlimited hires out of us but also
different aspects so kind of the full
recruitment
um
aspect to it so that could be benefits
package or you know their branding or
something like that so they kind of get
everything
um from us so yeah it's um it's
definitely different to agency there
isn't uh absolutely aspect to it and I
think it's really nice to kind of focus
on one client at one time
um and it's definitely yeah it's it's
been a big shock to the system but I've
definitely liked it doing it
yeah and then just and then just help us
understand and so like I can see that so
you worked
um for a company for it looks like six
months so like like you said there's
loads of different factors that redcub
can support them with but in terms of
like what what did you mainly focus on
was you just basically mainly focusing
on the live vacancies that you agree
that you're going to support them with
or you're working on and then you as
very much focused on the candidate side
yeah so um when you initially go in you
still do onboarding like you're a normal
employee
um or at least with my project we did
and then we look at their entire
forecast of the highest that they want
to make for that year and kind of the
targets that they've set for themselves
um and then we essentially take a
portion of those roles
um and help hire for them
um in terms of other kind of day-to-day
bits it's obviously still very heavily
sourcing so you still have that aspect
of
um agency it's not just kind of focusing
on their inbound applicants you're
bringing the value of an agency in terms
of passive candidates and sourcing and
things like that but I also helped with
like convention you know their benefits
package and how we can make that more
attractive to candidates and and things
like that
okay brilliant lovely thank you thank
you for sharing that so that's really
helpful so I think that'll just yeah set
this in for people and like the sort of
environment that you've been in for the
last six to eight months so what what
skills or experiences recruitment giving
you then that may be least expected
early so far do you think
um I would say confidence but more
self-confidence I'm always a very
confident person and outgoing
um but I tend to kind of over analyze or
overthink
um you know certain situations and I
think being in recruitment has really
allowed me to be confident
um with what I'm saying and and how I'm
acting and what I'm doing it's just
really really leveled that up because
you kind of see the impact that you're
making throughout that
um and a lot of self-awareness is
probably the the biggest one a lot of
self-awareness
I love that and then how that I hope you
don't mind me asking but like this has
been such a common answer and I think
this is why so many more people should
consider a career in recruitment because
of these types of things like I just I
think more confident people in our world
means potentially more happier people or
more self-awareness people in our world
more happy people potentially or at
least it's going to have an impact so
like how was that how is that more
self-awareness how is that more
self-confidence manifested in your in
your personal life
I think it's being able to understand
different point of views and and
different people and different
situations and and understand in terms
of being self-aware understanding when
to listen understanding when to talk
understanding when to give value
um you know things can be especially
when you're at Uni there's so many
different opinions and you don't
necessarily know how to navigate that
whereas when you kind of apply it to a
professional aspect you know how to
navigate that situation and you know how
to add value to it so that's definitely
helped in terms of social situations and
then in confidence it's just kind of
being able to go about day-to-day life
and and you know feel happy Within
Myself and and happy with what I'm doing
and and being able to show that off but
not in a you know too much too much of
an arrogant way
no that's brilliant that I I absolutely
love that so
so let's just let's just focus then for
a second before we really get into the
weeds of like the last couple of months
like
how how did Ellie navigate and deal with
the pressure of graduating with a degree
and then figuring out what the hell you
want to do with your life and getting
the perfect job with your now
criminology a degree like how did you
deal that pressure because I didn't go
to university and I I've obviously done
these sort of podcasts before and the
sort of just to hear my take on it and
then you can let me know how you felt on
what manifested for you but when I have
spoken to graduates there really does
sort of feel that I do sense this sort
of real undercurrent of like pressure
from on themselves pressure they get by
their parents by their friends on Ellie
has just obviously graduated with this
degree and now to make it all worthwhile
she has to get a job that reflects all
that work that money that has gone into
that and it sort of can almost paralyze
people on putting themselves forward for
things getting a job or trying different
things
um because they feel like it has to be
the perfect role uh how did you deal
with that pressure and did you have that
pressure
oh 100 had the pressure from both my dad
and my mum who were kind of like why
would you go into Recruitment and not
something to do with criminology like
you said that you were going to but I
think it was justifying it by applying
like soft skills that you learn at
University
um I think the subject was you know
subject of criminology is great but
there was so much more from that degree
that I got than just the subject of
criminology like researching skills
analytical skills being able to present
and and things that you can all apply to
recruitment or any other career so for
me it wasn't necessarily a pressure of
oh my God I'm not doing anything with my
criminology degree it was more of a I'm
taking this aspect from a degree that I
got at University and I'm going to apply
it to a job and a job that I really want
to do because I didn't know what to do
with criminology I chose it when I was
18 probably because I watched too many
Criminal Minds episodes
um and then you know got to my third
year and I was like I have no idea what
to do with this and I don't think I'm
going to make a career of it so I found
a way
also I think that's a really great way a
great way great way of reframing it of
what you just said of like taking away
the actual subject matter that you
obviously graduated in but looking at
all the things on that Journey that it
helps you with so to sort of wrap that
up then what would your advice be for
someone that's listened to this right
now that's feeling really heavy with the
pressure of I've got all this debt I've
got the pressure from my parents that
want me to do well because they're my
paid some of my you know I don't know
they might have helped in some way
um I don't want to feel like a failure
because I just did graduate this degree
and I'm not getting a job that's
relevant to it like what would be your
overarching advice for people that yeah
might be feeling really stressed right
now
um I would say just run with it just
talk to anyone else that has finished
uni and ask them what they're doing
because in my experience about 90 of
them didn't go into something to do with
their degree but in terms of when you're
actually there at University coming
towards the end of that degree it's just
researching what else is in the market
and you know there's not a fine art
finite amount of jobs out there it's the
biggest thing that I've learned in
recruitment is how many different types
of jobs there are and there'll always be
something for someone just take that
small bit of something that interests
you and you could probably go and find
like 50 jobs that will kind of match
that so just normalizing it really and I
think that's what I've tried to do with
my personal brand my LinkedIn my Tick
Tock is just normalizing that way that
people feel and then they're not really
alone with it so yeah and what do you
feel about this I have my own opinion on
it but like what do you what do you feel
about people being less hung up on
getting the perfect job these types of
things and instead leaning to expand
experimenting trying different
Industries trying different jobs and not
getting really caught up on having a CV
that looks like you've tried loads
different jobs what do you think about
that now you're in recruitment on the
other side
um
I'm not too sure actually that's quite
an interesting question I suppose
trying new things is a part of
especially in this generation is part of
what we're about you know we kind of
dabble in everything but I think if you
hop to something and then you find what
you really love I I think that's great
um but no I've never been asked that
question it's actually really
interesting yeah
yeah so like for me the reason why I
asked that is again speak to a lot of
young people there's often this sort of
sentence you hear of like I don't want
to come across job puppy I don't want to
look this certain way and for me
personally like I think like I'm 29
years old so I feel like the best thing
to lean into and focus on in your 20s is
taking risk and trying and experimenting
different things trying different like
how you meant to how are you meant to
know if you like different foods without
trying them right and I feel like with
your career and work how are you meant
to how are you meant to know what you
want to do what you love doing as you
said without trying different things and
then when you've got to a point where
like you know what I actually really
like this role then it's like wow this
is exciting and I comply myself in the
rather I'm in or you can then see a
future for yourself but I think also a
lot of people can get hung up on Ellie
looking job hoppy having different jobs
but really I don't know I mean you're
you're in the seat that you're in I
don't know if you've seen it yeah did
you get what I mean so it's just like I
don't think that's gonna put off loads
of employers that people think if
they're honest about it and they share
this is what I've done
no 100 and I think for me I mean on my
LinkedIn it doesn't have that I had
millions of oh I'll say Millions I
didn't have loads but you know I had
maybe five jobs whilst I was at
University and in bars and different
things like that none of that's on my
LinkedIn but in terms of my previous
company before I came to the red cup it
probably does look a little bit weird
that I left after 10 months but for me
it was a big decision
um and it did take me a while to make
the decision I actually gave them three
months notice because I loved what I did
so much but for me it was the right move
in my career and I think when you
explain that to people and you explain
actually the long-term you know
Ambitions that you have for yourself and
why that company is going to fit into
that and why you're looking at making
the move the fact that you know you're
leaving the company after 10 months kind
of becomes redundant because you're
doing it for the right reasons and
you're doing it because you believe that
that company is kind of going to elevate
you and it's going to give you the
exposure that you want which the red
card has done for me it's definitely
paid off
exactly so what what has been so people
want to know this what has been your
biggest challenge so far on on this uh
Journey with recover specifically so
think of the last six eight months what
has been your biggest challenge we often
hear and I definitely got told it your
first year recruitment can be the
hardest what's what's been the most
difficult for you what's been your
biggest challenge
um I was actually thinking about this
and I probably have a really
really think where your first year is a
learning yeah it's kind of like a
learning bubble I don't think that
there's ever a biggest challenge I've
one week I could have a really really
hard challenge I could have a really
really hard day and then I overcome it I
bounce back from it and then the next
week or maybe a month later I can have
another one and it squishes whatever
that other bad day was so I wouldn't say
that I've got a biggest challenge or or
even kind of like a best moment you know
your first hire you'll probably say it's
your best moment but then when you make
a really really like high placement
um placement you know that then be your
biggest one so kind of in your first
year I would say like all those
different hurdles that you face are
probably going to be the hardest until
the next one comes along
so you mentioned bouncing back there
how's Ellie got better at bouncing back
um
I think I mentioned that
it's being able to set boundaries Within
Myself or not being still putting myself
in the job but kind of building a bit
more resilience and not you know taking
it too much to heart if something
doesn't go my way and especially working
from home it for me it's definitely just
stand up walk out the house go take a
five minute walk and come back fresh and
start you know start again but learn
from it as well
yeah that was gonna I was gonna ask you
yeah so you're a walker
I love that so I guess like how have you
how have you had that like a lot of
people concerned right about this like
have you adapted to like learning a new
market in this role particularly Tech
how have you gone about focusing on that
and sort of not again being paralyzed by
Ellie is a junior recruiter doesn't have
loads of experience so why would this
developer speak to me or why would the
senior person speak to me like have you
gone about yeah building that
self-confidence around learning a new
market
um so I obviously work with a 50
brilliant recruiters who all come from
amazing backgrounds and I just wasn't
afraid to ask them whether that you know
asked them to kind of walk through new
jargon to me or something like that or
you know ask to Shadow a call with them
and then as I slowly started to do that
I felt a lot more confident in myself
um and you know seeing them maybe do
have a hiccup on a screening called made
me feel a lot more confident even if
they did have seven years experience so
it's just really kind of not being
afraid to ask the question even with
candidates if you if you're just a bit
more you know kind of forthcoming with
it and say oh I actually don't know too
much about this so in my experience I'm
more than happy to kind of tell you what
they love to do so it's just kind of
asking the question
and then I guess a sort of uh you let me
know if you feel like you've had one of
these but have you have you had a penny
drop moment
and if so like like when did you feel
like you you got it
um it will probably be
I graduated University
since he said to me that he had no idea
that I was at University and thought I'd
been in recruitment for about five years
and to me that was like oh my God he
didn't think I was junior he didn't
think like this I and I didn't come
across that way and that gave me a lot
more confidence because he just didn't
know I'd been at Uni the entire time
and what why do you think he said that
was that because the way he was on the
phone or what you're talking about the
questions he was asking
yeah again I think it was me being
I I in my opinion I've kind of tried to
always bring something different to a
call that I thought would add value to
him even though it wasn't necessarily
asked whether that was you know market
research or a research you know
analytics of what the quarter looked
like for them or something like that and
it was an experience that he hadn't had
with the previous agency that you worked
with and
um I suppose maybe just kind of my
confidence
um even when I was on a call with say
the managing director and I kind of LED
that cool and he just kind of wouldn't
see the difference yeah it's a great
that's a great compliment so what
obviously a big part of your role is
focused on like you said taking that
sort of agency approach but internally
in terms of getting into the passive
candidate Market being proactive what
have you found
has been the most effective for you in
terms of building like sustainable
candidate relationships like what has
ended up really working for you is it
being head hunting people on LinkedIn
has it been calling people like I don't
know what what have you found has ended
up really sort of working for you and as
being the recipe
um I would say it's doing a lot of
different things I think when you're a
junior person you have so many people
kind of telling you their best practices
I took
excuse me I took a little bit of
everyone's and then kind of made my own
recipe so you know when I'm doing
LinkedIn messages if I can see somebody
spent hours you know building up their
presence on LinkedIn and they have a
really really good profile I will also
take the time to make that message a
little bit more personal to them also
connecting with them on LinkedIn and
starting a conversation with them on
there and just really building up that
Network because I think every
conversation you had or you have can
always maybe lead to something more
further down the line it doesn't have to
be that day it doesn't have to be that
job or that deal it could be further
down the line or or something like that
but I have also
um placed two candidates and processes
from Tick Tock as well so maybe it might
be another revenue for people to look at
yeah so yeah just trying different
things and I I think I really like that
mindset like you where you are today and
and that conversation may not be and be
something immediate today but it could
be in the long run I think that's a
sometimes it's hard to see that when
you're in the trenches of like your
first couple of months like building
relationships you know you'll have
likely senior people tell you that but
sometimes it can be hard to believe you
know but then when you have people start
coming back to you and these things so
um what I was going to say so it says in
your LinkedIn Ellen you've mentioned it
a few times that you are a remote work
advocate
yes I am indeed
so obviously around my camera you'd see
yeah so for those that aren't tuning on
video Ellie's definitely working from
home in a remote environment so I wanna
I wanna just get your take on this like
there's so there's such a debate on this
and for me my my stance on it is it is
so contextual uh on like the individual
and also I think if a company wants
their people in the office and that's
the culture they want to build then
that's their right and they can own that
and if people want to be part of that
great if people don't then that's fine
but like I guess
how you've mentioned a few things around
learning you're the least experienced
person in the business at the moment but
you're in a really supportive
environment like how have how have you
in a remote environment mainly I'm
assuming I don't know how often you go
into the office if at all
like how how have you learned like how
how have you made space to learn how
have you made time to speak to people
and learn from because a lot of people
will say the the sentence is what's
really great about people in the office
early on is they can hear Ellie the
senior recruiter on the phone they can
pinch things on that and like you know
you said earlier around taking little
Parts people really believe a lot of
people I speak to anyone believe that
you can do that way quicker in an office
environment so how have you how have you
like how have you done that in a remote
environment what does that look like I
think it started off really really easy
because I was in the pandemic
um well everyone's in the pandemic but I
was at Uni during the pandemic and we
went completely remote in my second year
and I have to learn still and I had to
do my degree and I had to do my
dissertation so it wasn't too much of a
transition for me but also everyone
lands in different ways and so I use so
many different tools like it might be a
YouTube video there's so many resources
out there at the very women of people
doing screening calls on YouTube and
things like that that I just went off
and you know took my laptop and learned
that way and like I said you know still
screen share and you can still kind of
listen in on people's screening calls
and Shadow and things like that so I
think definitely being a kind of remote
student helped me out a lot because it
wasn't too much of a transition
um but also like just being able to
kind of take control of my learning in
in the sense of not just using the
training materials that I was given but
actually actively going out and and
having a look what else was out there on
YouTube and you know I actually found
this podcast as well so I listened to
different podcasts and you just learned
so many different things and yeah
there's you can kind of use your eight
hours in the day kind of that way and
and not be necessarily shoved into
face-to-face training where you might
not always digest it everyone has
different ways of learning and how have
you how have you tapped into the
experience of your business so like do
you know what I mean because that that
that's what can take time right so if
we're in an office right now and I've
got five years experience and you're
sitting next to me like it's very easy
for you to go heesham I've just had this
kind of like say this to me what would
you do if you said that to you like that
that's quite that's quite hard to sort
of create that instantaneous those types
of things that could be really helpful
for people remotely so the the the
amount of experience you have in your
business is one of the great things that
you can tap into so have you have you
like do you have to really be proactive
in reaching out to people like do you do
something on a weekly basis where you
can there's an open Forum to tap into
this knowledge like how have you tapped
into that remotely
so um with us where the rec Hub is a
remote first company there are you know
there's not that many people that go
into the offices so there's uh we have
different offices around the UK I
sometimes go into the London office
maybe once or twice a month but we have
we use slack and we have so many
different channels like support channels
and things like that where you can
either ask the question or you could
probably scroll up and find the answer
to your question and I think that's a
nice good way as well because if one
person has a question nine times out of
ten you know other people are going to
have that question and you kind of got
that on as a Keepsake and then from my
team we still do you know morning
meetings where we can kind of
collaborate on different challenges and
and things like that so you still kind
of get to have that collaboration and
then kind of as a business as a whole
outside of like just my team we still
have like once a week pods where you get
to meet different people in the company
and get to experience well you get to
ask people about different experiences
and things like that so it doesn't feel
like
as isolated as what I think most people
think it is it still feels very you know
everyone's together and everyone's
helping each other and there's a lot of
support out there and everyone's more
than willing to you know help out if you
if you need them to they'll kind of give
you five minutes in their day if you
need to
yeah awesome thanks Jen that's some good
insights there okay so final thing on
this because I know this is interesting
for people
just final thing would be like again
these are these some I'm sort of trying
to communicate the Assumption play devil
advocate here and like the assumptions
out there right and I'm sure you've
heard these and see these online
as a young person in work I feel
personally but I feel like a big part of
why people want to
um go into the office work or a big part
of why people look forward to work is
the social element
um being able to meet new people make
new friends maybe even create a romantic
relationship it happens a lot in work
right and these types of things so do
you feel like Ellie's missed out on that
because you're remote first do you feel
like you've still got that I think this
is another assumption as well as a young
person do you feel like you've missed
that out or you're not getting that part
that a lot of people really enjoyed as
part of working in London in different
places
oh 100 not no so we've got like
different clubs and societies which I'm
a part of so we've got the health Hub
we've also got the book club so I'm also
in that and
um you know like I said I still go up to
the office maybe once or twice a month
and that's really really nice because
it's like
it's like seeing people that you haven't
seen in a while so you have so much more
to catch up on rather than just kind of
day-to-day Chit Chat and we all go out
after work and and that's a lot nicer
but I don't feel like that I don't have
the social aspect because there's so
many more things that we kind of do to
I kind of help out with that like we
throw in different ideas the quarterly
meetups are absolutely brilliant they're
so much fun we've got so much to kind of
talk about in in that sense and we've
got there are people at the rec Hub who
you know live in different countries and
sometimes travel as well because we can
work you know anywhere in Europe and
things like that so I think it's I think
it's kind of subsidized with how great
the kind of remote culture is and
everyone that we work with I think
definitely kind of have the same
um like fun element to them
there's no one that kind of doesn't get
involved
um everyone kind of gets involved with
everything and they can start a new Hub
um you know Club if they want to I think
somebody was talking about starting a
wine club I don't know that was quite
popular so yeah I think the social
elements definitely still there and I
think people as a society has gotten
used to still having social aspects to
their lives like especially during the
pandemic and it's just a way to
incorporate it into your work life
yeah okay brilliant so a couple lost
things then before we finish
uh so I really wanted to get your
thoughts on this what's been the best
training advice that you've received
that's really worked for you since dying
um there's been so many I've had such
great mental so if I pick one of them
and
I think it would be
just ask questions and that that
generally applies to every aspect and I
think I say it quite a lot I think one
of them that I received quite recently
was that time kills deals and and that
that was kind of very relevant to my
situation and kind of helped me out
quite a bit but yeah I think everyone
gives great advice but I would
definitely just say ask a question I
mean you don't you don't ask you don't
get yeah uh what do you wish you knew
before joining the industry
[Music]
much of a big part of your personal
brand can have on your success in
recruitment
it was definitely something that I think
I wish I had started a little bit
earlier and it's definitely I'm still on
the Journey of my personal brand and
stuff like that but yeah
brilliant so final question
so a bit of a sort of scenario here and
then you can be honest with me and let
you know if you think this would be
really helpful for for people so if you
could pick one thing about the
environment that you joined that has
allowed you to succeed so far
what do you think it would be so it
could be it could be
um so so for example to watch it so that
it will help us understand what people
should look for in the company when
engineering recruitment right so in
terms of yeah some of the things it
might be culture training incentives the
right Market way of working like if you
could pick one thing out of the
environment that you sort of experienced
so far wreck Hub that you feel has
really enabled you to sort of excel what
would it be do you think
I think it would be autonomy and
flexibility to say have my own work set
up and work in the way that I want to
work and having you know the directors
and the company really advocate for that
and really push for you to kind of work
in the way they best suits you has been
really really helpful for me so that
would be kind of my number one one there
we go remote work Advocate absolutely
yeah living by it yeah I think I think
look I I know we've focused on that
quite a bit but I think that's really
helpful just to get a real honest
perspective from Someone Like You on
your journey because there's positive
there's pros and cons it's gonna be
right for some people not right for
other people but clearly here this is
really working for you and you're
enjoying it and if that's the one thing
that you think has really enabled you to
be happy in your role enjoy your work
and you're in yeah enjoying the journey
that you're on then then that's amazing
uh and I think that's awesome so I guess
before we finish then parting parting
words of wisdom Ellie for people that
are on a similar journey to you they're
in the trenches right now what what
advice do we have for people that uh
early on on their their recruitment
career but before we finish
um I would just say do your due
diligence go out and research what
you're actually going to want whether
that's embedded agency you know RPO
really kind of have a look at what's
going to suit you and also the industry
that you're going to work with but I
think companies the biggest one like
really go and speak to the people that
work in the company before you join
because they'll be honest
Ellie thank you so much